hélène frade est avec tous on va avoir
avec vous bonjour hélène un jour
plaideraient que dit la presse
internationale ce matin on parle bien
sûr de cette opération militaire russe
lancé cette nuit contre l'ukraine où des
explosions ont été entendues de
plusieurs villes du pays notamment dans
la capitale kiev la russie attaque
l'ukraine annonce ce matin de washington
post qui cite le discours convient
d'évoquer ici à l'instant de vladimir
poutine quelques minutes avant le début
des opérations
la situation nous oblige à prendre des
mesures décisives et rapide a déclaré le
président russe en ajoutant que moscou
procéderait je le cite toujours à la
démilitarisation et à la dénazification
de l'ukraine selon le site du journal
d'opposition à novaïa gazeta
cité notamment par le monde les
métadonnées de l'intervention de ce
matin ce de cette déclaration de guerre
montrerait que celle ci aura été
enregistré lundi soir à 19 heures heure
de moscou c'est à dire en même temps que
le long discours dans lequel vladimir
poutine annonçait la reconnaissance des
républiques séparatistes
d'ukraine des semaines de diplomatie
intense et l'adoption de sanctions
occidentales n'ont pas réussi à
dissuader poutine qui a massé entre 150
mille et deux cent mille soldats le long
des frontières l'ukrainienne annonce de
masques au times qui cite lui la
réaction du président américain joe
biden le président poutine a choisi une
guerre prémédité qui entraînera des
pertes de vies humaines et des
souffrances humaines catastrophique hier
le secrétaire général de l'onu avait
dénoncé les violations commises par
moscou à l'égard de kiev il a l'occasion
de l'ouverture d'une réunion de
l'assemblée générale antonio perez a
prévenu que le monde faisait face à un
moment de péril une déclaration le voit
à la une du journal britannique et
independiente qui précise sur son site
que le président russe a menacé cette
nuit quiconque tenterait d'interférer
dans ce conflit ils doivent savoir que
la réponse de la russie sera immédiate
et conduire à des conséquences encore
jamais connu côté ukrainien le
gouvernement à déclarer l'état d'urgence
on le sait dans tout le pays demander à
tous ses ressortissants de quitter la
russie ait annoncé la mobilisation
ces réservistes au moment même où
vladimir poutine lui qu'on retrouve à la
une du guardian participaient à une
cérémonie de dépôt de gerbe sur la tombe
du soldat inconnu à l'occasion de la
journée du défenseur de la patrie une
image évidemment extrêmement symbolique
et quelles sont les premières réactions
on écrème l'ats le rédacteur en chef du
site d'informations sensor qui dit se
trouver près de dos n'y est qu'un l'est
du pays enjoint ses compatriotes à ne
pas avoir peur l'ukraine va gagner vos
croire youri bluetooth off qui évoque je
le cite l'un des moments les plus
sombres de l'histoire de l'ukraine
j'entends la guerre écrit-il mais nous
sommes unis par une confiance commune
l'ukraine s'est forgé dans la lutte pour
la liberté l'ukraine deviendra plus
forte je le cite dans la lutte pour la
liberté l'opération lancée par le
kremlin en ukraine est perçue par une
partie la presse internationale comme le
signe d'une radicalisation de la ligne
qui est le quotidien français la croix
parle d'une fuite en avant s'alarme de
la vision victimaire que gauthier a
évoqué à l'instant dans laquelle le
patron du kremlin semble s'être enferré
le journal cite lui l'analyse de la
directrice du centre russie de
l'institut français des relations
internationales sur les discours très
violent de vladimir poutine ces derniers
jours on a l'impression que l'émotion la
rancune et la haine envers l'ukraine et
la volonté de réparer les injustices
historiques supposé pèsent bien plus que
le coût qu'elle le calcul coût bénéfice
pour le président russe qui pourraient
être ainsi à quel point il est le seul
maître à bord le spectateur s'interroge
lui sur les buts poursuivis par vlad
l'envahisseur représentée par mme
automne bolen on le voit ici dans
l'uniforme taille est trop grand pour
lui de l'armée soviétique
jusqu'où le président russe est il prêt
à aller at-il en réalité perdu le
contrôle après tant d'années passées au
pouvoir le magazine britannique
conservateur se demande si le président
russe n'a pas fini par perdre ses
instincts politique au fil des années
une évolution extrêmement dangereux
selon de spectateurs ont convié la
presse russe
alors il respecte les proches du kremlin
martèle que l'intervention de l'armée
russe fait suite à l'aggravation de la
situation militaire dans les territoires
séparatistes du donbass dont les chefs
se seraient tournés vers le kremlin pour
repousser l'agression je cite du
gouvernement ukrainien non l'armée russe
n'a pas effectué de tirs de missile
aérien ou d'artillerie sur les villes
d'ukraine à celle le quotidien qui cite
ici le ministère de la défense de la
fédération de russie l'ukraine veut tard
mais tout ce qu'ils peuvent tenir une
arme à la main contre évidemment les
séparatistes sans surprise le site
nationaliste svoboda y après ça reprend
telle quelle la propagande du kremlin
sur une supposée attaque massive est
imminente un de l'ukraine contre les
séparatistes
le site reprend lui aussi les
communiqués du ministère de la défense
russe qui souligne que toutes les
frappes militaires toutes les frappes de
missiles par nom par les troupes russes
sont menés contre les infrastructures
les entrepôts l'aviation et la chouette
ukrainiens qu'il s'agit de frappe de
haute précision militaire et que
personne je cite ne va bombarder les
villes et les réactions ailleurs dans le
monde hélène du à 7 ou des voix la
guerre froide ravivées par cette
intervention russe estime que la
politique étrangère américaine est de
nouveau mise à l'épreuve après le
désastre du retrait des états unis
d'afghanistan en chine de global times
estime non seulement pauline que les
sanctions occidentales ne permettront
pas de résoudre cette crise ukrainienne
mais il met aussi en garde les
etats-unis contre toute décision qui
porterait atteinte aux intérêts
légitimes d'autres pays je cite la chine
évidemment dans leur gestion de cette
crise entre la russie et l'ukraine enfin
le journal britannique the times relais
les craintes exprimées par washington
sur les répercussions pour l'europe de
cette invasion russe en ukraine qui
pourrait déclencher je cite l'une des
plus grandes crises de réfugiés au monde
avec possiblement jusqu'à 5 millions de
personnes déplacées merci hélène pour
cette revue de presse